hey 42 here this is the Mediterranean
Sea segmented from the Atlantic Ocean by
the Strait of Gibraltar it has all the
attributes you'd expect for Mercy namely
a grand snaking Coastline over 28 000
miles all tolls in fact whether it's the
Red Sea the Black Sea or the Yellow Sea
all Seas have a coastline right a
tangible Rocky border that you can see
feel and walk upon
well
not all of them because this is to
sargassoci and unlike every other sea on
Earth
has no Coastline but how then is it a
see it all well I'm glad you asked
situated in the Atlantic Ocean the
sargasso sea is delineated not by land
but by the mighty ocean currents
enclosing it
these currents comprising of the Gulf
Stream the North Atlantic drift the
canary current and the north equatorial
current form an immense swirling Vortex
called the North Atlantic gyre that
perfectly isolates the sargasso sea from
the rest of the ocean meaning it doesn't
have a coastline but rather an ocean lie
and the delineation between water within
the bounds of the sargasso and outside
it it's not just a technicality there's
something fundamentally different and
unusual about this water and as you're
about to discover this strange sea
conceals a few hidden Wonders that you
won't find anywhere else on Earth
are you tired of spending precious time
preparing meals when you have a busy
schedule I know I am well let me
introduce you to huel Black Edition your
super nutritional Time Saver cure Black
Edition is an amazing 100 nutritionally
complete meal last plant-based
gluten-free and high-end protein with
low carbs it's packed with 26 essential
vitamins and minerals and it's ready in
just 30 seconds to make a heel Shake I
simply add 500 mL of water to my heel
shaker bottle add two scoops of fuel
powder and give it a good shake my
favorite is this Black Edition chocolate
I cannot believe this stuff is good for
me because it's so rich and chocolatey
and it tastes really really good I
especially like to start my day on
protein because protein is so essential
to pretty much every function of the
body and the protein packed breakfast
just puts my body on the right track for
the rest of the day each serving of fuel
contains a massive 40 grams of protein
and loads of fiber with less than five
percent sugar oh did I mention it's also
really affordable so just click the Link
in the description below to try huel
today and if you use my special link
you'll be supporting the channel and
you'll also get a free heel shaker
bottle so don't miss out and thanks to
huel for sponsoring this video
Christopher Columbus was the first to
mention this bit of sea during the Age
of Exploration he was captivated by the
extensive floating seaweed mats he
encountered describing them as forests
in the sea and like most forests
sargasso has an uncanny Tranquility to
it rarely found on the high seas the
surrounding currents act like protective
walls rendering the waters within
exceptionally calm with minimal winds
this has given birth to Legends of ships
becoming ensnared within the sea unable
to break free from its motionless Waters
one such unsettling tale is that of the
French merchant ship Rosalie which
vanished Without a Trace in 1840. the
ship was later discovered drifting
aimlessly in the sargasso sea with not a
single person on board she'd been
completely abandoned yet the sails were
set the cargo was untouched and the
crew's personal belongings were still on
board
but there was no sign of a struggle or
any indication of what happened to the
crew and to this day we still don't have
an answer
weirdly nobody actually knows how big
the sargasso sea is after all its
borders are constantly changing with the
ocean currents but it's roughly 1800 by
600 nautical miles however if you're
traveling nearby you'll know you've hit
the sargasso when the color of the water
below becomes a deep absorb blue the
almost translucent sargasso offers
visibility of up to 60 meters deep so
this surprisingly Serene sea devoid of a
coastline is an odd place indeed but
there's something even more bizarre
bubbing upon its surface it's called
sargassum seaweed and it has a lord
explorers scientists and sailors alike
throughout history sargassum a brown
microalgae is speckled with tiny
gas-filled sacks known as pneumaticists
these air filled Pockets allow the
seaweed to float gracefully atop the
ocean's surface forming these extensive
Tangled rafts that Meander with the
currents and this rather clever seaweed
functions as a carbon sink it absorbs
and stores atmospheric carbon dioxide
thus mitigating the impacts of global
warming
boasting a one-of-a-kind morphology the
two main species sargassum Nations and
sargassumfluritans coalesce to form
substantial seaweed structures that
stretch for hundreds of miles some are
even detectable from space
they're so large that throughout history
they've acted as navigational landmarks
for seafarers the seaweeds consist in
presence allows Sailors to verify their
location and prevent confusion amidst
the enormous otherwise featureless ocean
but as sargassum surges in size it has
sparked speculation that a sprawling
mass of it spanning several hundred
miles might wash up on Florida's beaches
upon which it would slowly decompose
discharging hydrogen sulfide exuding the
scent of rotten eggs naturally this
would negatively impact tourism because
nothing says Beach holiday like a
mountain of rotting goo next to your
Cabana that smells like putrid giant
hence boats now frequently battle these
bothersome bmoths breaking them up
before they besiege Florida's Margarita
Mary masses
sargassum has always mystified Mariners
Sailors spun intricate Yarns of
Fantastical creatures lurking within its
Tangled recesses all of ships hopelessly
trapped by its unyielding grasp like
mermaids it said that sargassum can drag
men and boats to their Peril and no
doubt it has contributed to the Bermuda
Triangle Mysteries an area that the
sargasso sea overlaps
it's believed the Phoenicians a
seafaring civilization that originated
in the Eastern Mediterranean around 1550
BC may have actually discovered the
sargasso sea long before that Columbus
chap the Phoenicians were known for
their Advanced navigational skills and
Maritime prowess and recent discoveries
of Phoenician artifacts such as Pottery
shards and shipwrecks in this sargasso
suggest that these ancient Mariners may
have ventured here thousands of miles
away from their Homeland
[Music]
the Phoenicians were likely drawn to the
sargasso due to the abundant resources
it offered including fish and the
valuable sargassum seaweed which could
be used for various purposes such as
medicine dye and even a source of
precious metals like gold but just think
what this means for a second if an
ancient Phoenician civilization visited
this remote watery World on the other
side of the Atlantic might they have
gotten that bit farther and landed in
the Americas two and a half thousand
years before legendary Viking Explorer
Leaf Erickson
perhaps and to add weight to this crazy
theory in 1872 a stone inscribed with
Phoenician writing was Unearthed in
Brazil there's still debate about its
authenticity but it describes a
Phoenician ship separated from its Fleet
in a storm
could that for lawn vessel have served
to sargasso Sea eventually saundering
its way to South America
we don't know but it's a tantalizing
thought
for centuries those navigating the
sargasso have told of peculiar noises
echoing through the water some have
ascribed this two agonized whales of
lost souls and snared within the seaweed
whilst others blame various sea beasties
contemporary research however has
unveiled that what they were hearing are
snapping shrimp which used their claws
like spring-loaded pistols to generate
tiny Sonic rooms underwater to
disorientate and immobilize their prey I
actually did a whole video about them if
you'd like to know more
the floating seaweed islands of the
sargasso serve as a vital Oasis for many
highly specialized creatures remarkably
some of these are endemic to the
sargasso meaning they are found nowhere
else on Earth just think how crazy that
is there are literally creatures that
exist only in this sea that's entirely
within an ocean that's only borders are
ocean currents
weird in fact the sargasso sea is often
called The Floating rainforest because
of the remarkable range of biodiversity
in this otherwise desolate region of the
ocean over 100 fish species 145 and
vertebrates and even 10 sharks call
these supposedly silent Waters their
home this wealth of life has led some to
propose that the sargasso sea should be
recognized as one of Earth's natural
wonders
although not endemic one enchanting
Denizen is the baby sea turtle upon
hatching on Caribbean Shores these tiny
Heroes embark on an Epic Quest seeking
shelter and Mr sargassum's protective
embrace the seaweed delivers both
nourishment and camouflage allowing
these defenseless hatchlings to dodge
the hordes of predators that seek to
gobble them up another Resident avoiding
Predators here is the Atlantic white
Marlin pregnant females release their
eggs within the Tangled seaweed mats
providing a secure Haven for their
offspring to mature this novel spawning
strategy is exclusively used by this
fish
there is a creature so well adapted to
these Waters it's actually named after
it histrio histrio better known as the
sargassum fish its body is adorned with
weed-like protrusions and it has mottled
skin expertly mimicking the seaweed's
appearance which allows it to camouflage
within the anti-social sargassum employs
a stealthy hunting tactic lying in
weight for unsuspecting prey to wander
too close to the seaweed then with
lightning fast reflexes and lethal
accuracy it strikes swallowing its
Target whole okay we get it you'd like
to be left alone
now if you've ever watched my video on
how eels reproduce you may recall a
sargasso sea as their potential breeding
ground or should that be breeding C
anyway we think these mysterious
creatures Journey thousands of miles
from their European freshwater homes to
the sargasso Sea where they spawn and
lay their eggs the resulting juvenile
eels known as leptocephali drift back to
Europe on ocean currents eventually
morphing into more recognizable adult
eels at least we think that's what
happens as crazy as it sounds we
actually don't know how eels reproduce
and they're probably the most confusing
and least understood mystery of the
sargasso sea but I won't get into all
that here just go watch my video on them
it's fascinating stuff honestly
the sargasso sea really is its own
little planet in the middle of the ocean
symbiosis where species partake in
mutually advantageous interactions is a
recurring theme Here tiny Crustaceans
munch on algae and detritus which
concurrently supplies essential
nutrients for the seaweed to flourish
and then when that seaweed breaks down
it releases vital nutrients such as
nitrogen and phosphorus back into the
water these nutrients fuel microscopic
organisms like phytoplankton which forms
the foundation of the marine food chain
and so on and so on
since the sargassoc occupies
international waters no single nation
can lay claim to it and so its
preservation and future rely on global
cooperation hence in 2014 the Hamilton
declaration for the conservation of the
sargasso sea was signed in which
numerous governments and organizations
pledged their commitment to generally
keep an eye on the sargasso and not mess
about with it too much it's basically a
worldwide pinky promise to not it
up which I guess is better than nothing
the sargassoci is a special part of
Earth's natural Legacy it's astounding
biodiversity ecological importance and
cultural worth make it an invaluable
asset for Humanity's future
but the biggest threats to the sargasso
is predictably all of Humanity's shite
you've heard of the Great Pacific
Garbage Patch I presume
well let me introduce you to its
lesser-known relative the North Atlantic
garbage patch
swirling Vortex of plastic packaging and
assorted debris has set up shop in a
particular corner of the North Atlantic
Ocean unfortunately all of this assorted
flots and flows right through the
sargasso sea worming its way through the
calm Waters where it inevitably becomes
entangled with the sprawling sargassum
seaweed mats This spells disaster for
the sargasso's special Critters and its
fragile ecological equilibrium
microplastic munching by tiny marine
organisms can kick off a chain reaction
of bioaccumulation of plastic within the
food chain which will ultimately affect
larger Predators taking on the Herculean
task of eradicating the North Atlantic
Garbage Patch calls for a cocktail of
cleanup Crusades such as the ocean
cleanup and the five gyres which are
hard at work extracting plastic waste
from the oceans and in the future
Innovative technology might help matters
but ultimately this plastic book stops
with us
thanks for watching